>>Bernhard Seefeld: Okay.
Welcome.
Today we talk about the future of Google Maps.
In this session, we're going to show you a
few more things of the demo you just saw in
the keynote and then we'll go into the new
API things that Mano and Ken are going to
talk about.
Do you like the demo?
[ Applause ]
>>Bernhard Seefeld: Okay.
Great.
So my name is Berni, and this is Yatin.
He was the engineering lead on the project
and he's going to show you few things.
Thanks.
So I thought we could start and look at three
things that we couldn't show at the keynote.
So one of the things is the related places.
You saw that I clicked on the museum and then
other museums showed up on the map and then
you could go around and explore and explore.
So one cool thing is that we can turn it,
actually, into a map on the entire world.
So there's a place here nearby called Monk's
Kettle.
People from San Francisco might know it.
It's known for a great beer selection.
It's a really great pub.
It has a great beer selection.
And you see now that I've searched for it,
all other places show up that are -- like
Gestalt is a bar nearby that also has a great
beer selection.
And if I zoom out, I'll get more places like
that: Seven Hills, Daily Grill.
They're all great.
But one cool thing is I can go further and
further, and then I can, for example, go and
zoom into Austin.
Anyone here from Austin?
>>> Yeah.
Right here.
>>Bernhard Seefeld: Okay.
So we'll see whether this actually works,
but you're verifying that those places are
good.
So now we see that the Eastside Showroom shows
up, and the Contigo, and before, I got some
-- the Flying Saucer Draught Emporium.
That sounds pretty -- is that right?
>>> Yeah.
>>Bernhard Seefeld: So we generated a whole
map for the entire world that is now about
bars with great beer.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>>Bernhard Seefeld: Isn't that great?
So Yatin is going to show you another one
of those photo tours.
>>Yatin Chawathe: Berni showed you a photo
tour of the inside of the Vatican.
What I'm going to show you is another photo
tour that takes us to an even larger scale,
so you can see that we can sort of make this
thing work not just at -- for a single landmark
like the St. Peter's Basilica but even an
entire city's worth of information.
So this here is a view of the Houses of Parliament
in the center of London, and I am going to
start the photo tour and just watch how it
sort of shows you a little bit of the Houses
of Parliament, and now it's just you turn
around and you see Big Ben right in the corner
over there, and it's going a little further
away, showing you a little bit more -- actually,
that wasn't Big Ben.
That was the other tower at the other end.
There now you start to see the Big Ben.
These are views of the Big Ben and the Houses
of Parliament taken from the London Eye by
users just like you uploaded to Google, and
here's the entire city of London seamlessly
stitched together into a very, very compelling
3D experience.
And Jonah Jones, who was helping Berni with
the demo live at the keynote, and I are going
to have a full session on how some of the
technical and design details of the new Google
Maps work.
This will be on Friday, I believe, at 9:00
a.m., so come join us there if you have more
questions.
And I'll hand it back to Berni to show you
just one other tidbit from the new Google
Maps.
>>Bernhard Seefeld: Okay.
Thanks.
So we use actually cinematic principles to
steer the camera.
The algorithm knows the dramatic effects that
are required to get to this stage, so very
cool.
So you should definitely go.
So I have a question.
Does anybody know what happened last Thursday
afternoon?
Anyone from Australia here?
You cheated.
Nobody?
Yell it out.
>> (Speaker is off microphone - Eclipse)
>>Bernhard Seefeld: Very well.
So what we're going to do now is go and change
the system time to last Thursday.
A little bit later.
I think like 5:00 p.m. would be good.
Okay.
So we go back here.
What is happening?
So let's go to Earth and start zooming out.
Let's see the world.
And so now that we look here at the sun, you
see that there is a little black spot here.
So that's the moon.
And then we turn around.
So the -- I told you that the stars and the
Milky Way and the sun were in the correct
position, so is the moon, and it's actual
like a simulation of the sunlight going to
Earth and the moon is in the middle, so we
saw this solar eclipse.
And actually we were just practicing the keynote
last Thursday and we looked at this screen
and we're like, "Shit!"
[ Laughter ]
>>Bernhard Seefeld: "Why do we have a black
spot on Earth?"
[ Laughter ]
>>Bernhard Seefeld: Then we just turned around.
We're like, "Why is there a black spot?
Ohhhh!"
Then we went online and there was indeed a
solar eclipse, so it was kind of funny.
All right.
So this is -- well, I wouldn't suggest you
should change your system time all the time
but it's like one of the neat things.
So wait for the next eclipse and then just
go on line.
So okay, with that, I'll go back to the slides.
I think I just pressed the wrong...
>>Ken Hoetmer: The laptop might have turned
off.
>>Bernhard Seefeld: Okay.
Thanks.
And so here's the agenda that I should have
told you before.
I guess these were the three interesting things
about the new Google Maps and then you'll
get an update on the new Google Maps APIs
and the next million maps.
And before I hand it over, I'd like to recommend
you sign up or recommend to your friends our
online courses, and they go through how to
use the new Google Maps, Maps Engine Lite,
and Google Earth.
Just go to g.co/mapping course and there will
be online courses, massive online courses
that you can take and help you learn a lot.
Thanks.
>>Ken Hoetmer: All right.
So my name is Ken.
I'm a product manager for the Google Maps
APIs based in Sydney and I'm going to talk
to you a bit about some new things we have
coming up in Google Maps APIs.
So as I do that, I'm just going to tackle
the obvious question -- I've seen it asked
on Twitter a number of times already -- and
just not beat around the bush and tackle it
straight up, which is: Are you going to announce
a new Google Maps API right now?
And the answer I have to give you, unfortunately,
is: No.
Remember that the new Google Maps that was
just demo'd in the keynote and that Berni
and Yatin have demo'd now is a preview.
That's not to say that we won't at some point
announce a new API based on the New Google
Maps, but we need to remember that this technology
is actually quite nascent and we still have
a lot to do with the product before we can
think about giving it to third parties.
So that's the bad news.
The good thing is, I do have an announcement
and I think it's an announcement you're find
very compelling and it may just be sort of
the largest visible change that we've introduced
to Google Maps APIs in the last eight years
that we've been around.
To do that, I'm going to set up by taking
a look at what the Google Maps API Version
2 looked like circa 2006.
Now, you can see on this map the familiar
pieces of the Google Maps API: the red pin,
the info window, the same kinds of familiar
yellow and blues of the Google Map base map.
The info window, as you can see, circa 2006
had nice rounded corners as all good Web 2.0
products did at that time, as well as we had
an incredibly large shadow, which was also
popular in Web 2.0 in the 2006 era.
If you flip forward to Google Maps API circa
2013, can anyone spot the difference?
I'll flip back, flip forward.
We squared off the corners on the info window,
certainly.
So Web 2.0 is over.
We still have the same pin.
We still essentially have the same info window.
We still have the same design and base map.
We introduced Street View, of course, in 2007
and that came into the API.
When we relaunched Version 3 of the JavaScript
Maps API we actually added support for mobile.
But essentially what you're seeing between
these two -- 2006 and 2013 -- in seven years
is essentially the same product.
Loads of new features but essentially the
same look.
Now, when you compare this to the new Google
Maps, which we've been talking about a lot
already today, you see a completely new experience
in the new Google Maps.
The base maps are a completely different design
and set of colors.
The marker is different.
There are no info windows, really, anymore.
Everything is sort of pulled to cards onto
the -- onto the left-hand side of the screen.
And the control experience is completely different
as well.
We have a carousel down at the bottom of the
map, rather than the zoom slider that you've
come to get used to on the left-hand side
of the map.
And when you look at the mobile applications
that were discussed in the keynote today as
well, they've also undergone a redesign that
aligns more closely with new Google Maps we
were talking about earlier.
Again, then you flip over to the Google Maps
API and I think I've kind of beat the dead
horse here long enough, but it's time for
a new look.
We're stuck in 2006 on Nokia 95s, waiting
for Wiis.
This is what was happening in 2006 while the
rest of Google Maps has moved along ahead
of us.
So here's what we're going to introduce.
It's called: google.maps.visualrefresh = true.
This is one line of code which is a global
property which you can add to your JavaScript
on your page and what it will do is it will
change the look and feel of the JavaScript
Maps API.
To illustrate, I'll just pull up the picture
that I was showing you earlier, and when I
applygGoogle.maps.visualrefresh = true, this
is what you get.
It's the same Google Maps API that you've
come to get used to and that's on now a million
sites we announced earlier, but it's been
refreshed with a brand-new more beautiful
design inspired by the work that's been done
in the mobile applications and now the new
Google Maps.
So these are the same base tiles that are
used in the new Google Maps, but rendered
as images not rendered as vector tiles in
the browser.
So we've taken the same design for the base
maps that's been used in the new Google Maps
and the mobile applications and brought it
into the JavaScript Maps API.
That's what I was going to talk about here,
one of the four major changes.
The second major change that we've introduced
is a new default marker.
So you would have seen on that screen that
we've removed the shadow from the marker that
you've come to know and love, and we've brought
in the marker that's now the default in the
new Google Maps.
The info windows, which I had commented on
a number of times earlier, have also undergone
a change.
The new info window is a much fresher, lighter
look and feel.
The shadow is gone on the info window as well.
And finally, the controls have undergone slight
change, just a fresh coat of CSS to bring
them into 2013.
Now, it's important to note that this is a
seamless transition and has been carefully
designed to be so.
So it's just one line of code that you add
to any Maps API application and it will just
enable the new look and feel.
Any custom markers, custom info windows, custom
tile overlays, custom -- custom map types,
anything that you've done to customize your
map will stay the same and will work as intended.
So this is just a transition of the UI elements.
And to illustrate that, I've just thrown up
a picture of the -- of the More Than a Map
showcase site that we have which I'll demo
in a second that we've upgraded to the new
look and feel just in the last half hour.
And of course we have another API, the static
maps API, which we've added the refresh to
as well.
It's a simple URL parameter and visual_refresh=true.
So with that, let's flip to the demo.
So here what I've got -- if you can see -- is
a side-by-side view of the classic Google
Maps API, if I can get this control to work.
Let's see if I can remember my URL.
Apparently that works.
So I've got side-by-side on the left the classic
version of the Google Maps JavaScript API
and on the right a refreshed version, and
these are running exactly the same code except
for the global property has been set on the
right.
So you can see the -- the older tiles on the
left a lot more yellow than on the right,
and this is the new design that's been introduced
in the new Google Maps.
If I zoom in, you'll see the same style of
maps as Berni was -- was showing earlier with
the same icons, et cetera.
We don't have the luxury of rendering vectors
in the browser and creating a new map for
every place, but we do have the same look
and feel that we can bring into the API.
If I open the info window, you can see side
by side the difference of the info windows.
In satellite mode, we've also changed the
labels in the hybrid view so that they're
freshened up with the new Google Maps look
and feel.
And everything else you can see remains the
same.
So peg man can still be dragged onto the map.
That works.
And everything is as expected.
If you flip over to a couple other different
places, here London -- and I show you on the
map -- you can see how the new look and feel
of the base maps actually really does change
the look of the maps API application.
In this case, it's a much fresher look.
So what I'm going to do now, to prove to you
that this is actually available now, you can
go change your site now, is go to MoreThanaMap.com,
which is our showcase case for the maps API,
flip over to demos, to base maps, and there
it is.
So it works.
Now, if I click on styled maps, styled maps
also still work the way they did before, and
I guess the point I'm getting at here is that
in some ways this is a non-announcement.
It's one line of code that changes the important
things but doesn't change all the customizations
that you've created.
Routing here as well works, going up to elevation
in San Francisco.
Again, it all looks as you would expect, but
we have a much brighter, fresher look to the
API.
I'll step back to my deck over here.
Great.
Now, I'll just talk a little bit about availability.
As I mentioned in the demo with MoreThanaMap.com,
this is available now.
It's available in both our experimental and
release branches for you to opt into.
And we're going to take this new look and
feel by default to the rest of the million
maps API sites on the web.
And the way that works is it will become default
on the experimental branch in three weeks
-- or in three months' time, in August, and
then three months later on the release branch,
which is the default branch for our enterprise
customers, in November.
Okay.
That's it for the announcement of the refresh.
The other thing I wanted to talk about was
to expand a bit on the numbers that Brian
announced in the keynote.
And the numbers he announced were that we
now have 1 million maps API sites and apps,
and the other is that these million API sites
maps are viewed by 1 billion unique visitors
a week.
Just sort of wrap your head around that one
while I do the little spinning animation.
To help you contextualize how big these numbers
are and why we think this is so important
to us is, you know, sometimes we don't think
about the scale and reach of the Maps API.
Keir Clark, I don't know if he's in the audience
but he generally reviews around three sites
or apps per day on the Google Maps Mania blog.
If he were to continue to do that at that
rate, it would take him 1,000 years to review
all of the Maps API sites in the world.
We now have Google Maps in 200 countries.
If you do simple math, 1 million divided by
200, you get 5,000, which means there are
roughly 5,000 of Maps API sites in every country
in the world.
And the last stat here that I want to throw
up there, because I think it's -- it's the
most interesting, especially given, you know,
what Larry was talking about today in the
keynote about bringing the Internet to the
rest of the world and a number of people have
talked about today, if we -- if we take that
there are roughly 2 1/2 billion people on
the Internet and we know that we get a billion
unique visitors to Maps API sites every week,
we can't exactly correlate unique visitors
to people because global networks sometimes
mean that multiple people hide behind the
same IP address and perhaps a number of us
in the -- in the audience here and myself
use multiple devices in a day, so it's really
hard to kind of work that out, but we do know
if we look at our numbers across a month,
we can very, very confidently say that half
the Internet sees a Google Maps API map every
month.
This is a quite an incredible distribution.
As we talk about that, it is interesting to
think about what kind of maps are these maps
that make up the million, right?
We have used hotel booking sites.
We used real estate sites.
But they don't make up the 1 million.
The 1 million has typically been made up of
really kind of local, innovative, inspirational
maps that developers have created themselves
because they had an idea or they saw a need
in a local community.
That's how you get a million around the world.
You do that in every country of the world
and you will get a million sites.
And so I just threw up an example here.
This is a transit simulator from Brasov, which
is a city in Romania.
How many of you have heard of Brasov?
I see one hand.
Brasov is a city of about 350,000 people in
Romania.
Somebody in the city released transit data
and then somebody else in the development
community created a map and an interactive
simulator of that transit data.
This kind of thing has been happening around
the world 1 million times.
Here is another interesting map.
This is an aid map from Haiti by an organization
that's a coalition of NGOs who are providing
aid after the earthquake in 2010 in Haiti.
What they do is they use this map to collaborate
on sharing information about the projects
they're doing so they can work more effectively
together.
In this case, this is an example of how people
have used maps and the ability to overlay
their own content on the maps for their specific
use case in a way that saves lives.
This is an application, planefinder, which
if you remember the opening video in the keynote,
it was actually featured there.
It is a data visualization.
Developers have been creating data visualizations
since the Maps API came out.
This one is fascinating.
You click on any airport in the world and
it creates this firework explosion in your
browser, showing you where all the planes
go.
It is fascinating.
This is another one here.
We talk about ways people have used the Google
Maps API with mashing it with other bits of
data to create really compelling and important
visualizations.
This is a map of articles in Wikipedia that
reference a place or articles of a place.
And the points on the map are colored based
on how many words have been written about
that place.
And what you get effectively is a population
density map.
It's fascinating.
Here's another one, just to illustrate the
ways the Maps API has been enabling communities.
There is loads of typography on buildings
in London.
Now I'm not a typography specialist or generally
a person who spends a lot of time looking
at it.
There are a lot of people in London who do,
it turns out.
And important for them is to document this
and share it.
Well, of course, they've used Google Maps
API Map.
Instant Street View is an interesting application
we saw show up.
This is where people have started to take
the maps API beyond just a basic map.
And Instant Street View here works like Google
Instant.
You start typing in and it takes you to different
places in the world with Street View.
Finally, GeoGuessr, how many of you have played
GeoGuessr?
See loads of hands.
Loads of hands.
Fascinating.
This is -- this is the latest viral site we've
seen created with the Maps API.
Very simple concept as they show you a bit
of Street View from somewhere in the world.
And your job is to click on the map where
you think the Street View was taken.
And you get points based on how close you
were to the right location.
It is incredibly educational and insanely
addictive.
So if you haven't played it, go try it out.
Now, it has been these kinds of applications
that have really inspired us.
So what we decided to do is to put together
a little video tribute which I'm going to
roll now and set up Mano Marks who will come
and talk about the next million maps.
[ Video playing ]
[ Music ]
[ Video ends ]
>>Mano Marks: Wow.
Sorry, I prestaged my slide.
Wow.
So, I have been on the Maps team, the Maps
and Earth team since about -- since 2006,
so about seven years now.
And I get teary when I see that video.
I get moved by the incredible changes that
we've made in the developers world but also
in the world of the Internet.
In 2005, 2006, the mashup revolution was born
and it started with people developing apps
with the Google Maps API.
That was the first monster mashup.
People realized that they could take services
that is a major corporation was providing
for free and mash them up with their own data.
We have moved a long way since then as you
have seen from the samples that Ken has shown.
But basically it's taking the power of maps
and putting them in the hands of developers
and putting them in the hands of people in
the world.
I didn't do a little spinny thing on the "wow"
like Ken did.
That's because I'm just spinning in my heart.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
So what I want to talk to you about now is
the next million apps, the next million maps
and how we are taking maps to new platforms.
You saw the new -- you saw the new Google
Maps in the keynote, the preview and you saw
it in Berni's talk here.
And what has become pretty clear to us -- and
also to pretty much everyone is that mobile
is the future, except it's not the future.
Mobile is not the future anymore; mobile is
the present.
And when Google Maps started, it was enough
to serve map tiles to a browser, and that
was pretty revolutionary at the time.
But we've looked beyond that.
And since the launch of Android, we've been
putting maps into the hands of mobile users.
But what we really want to do is put the same
mapping experience in the same map data into
the hands of every major -- every user on
a major platform.
You see here we have Web, mobile, Android
and iOS SDKs.
So we are really exciting that these are our
major platforms.
These are what you can see right now and what
you can develop on right now.
And the reason for that is that mobile data
is about 13% of global Internet traffic, according
to Mary Meeker's Internet trends report.
13%, but that's up considerably just from
last year.
And in some places in the world, it is the
majority of Internet traffic.
So we want to put powerful mapping experiences
and powerful map data that Google has and
that Google scale into your hands.
So when I say "On-Location," what I'm really
talking about is this concept of on location,
that your app is about more than just identifying
where somebody is, but it is about giving
them the entire context in which they -- in
which they are right now.
It's about giving them data.
It's about giving them, as you've seen, this
idea of what -- where are they going?
Not just knowing -- when you are building
an app, you don't to just want to know where
somebody is and you don't want to just ask
them where they're going, know where they
are going.
Get contextual information from your users
and build that into your applications.
Now, we see on the Maps team that there are
actually, we believe, three components to
this.
Now, there's the powerful visualization technologies
in the browser and on Android and iOS.
There's also our On-Location services.
So we've talked a lot for years about our
places API, our directions API, our geocoding
API, all of which can be used on a Google
Maps application.
And we've started recently talking about this
data platform.
I'm going to talk a little bit more about
that in a minute because I want to talk -- I
want to update you on the visualization platform.
Now, as I mentioned before, maps have been
about serving map tiles to a client application
that then just simply renders those map tiles.
That's what maps have been in the browser.
That's what maps have been on mobile devices.
In 2011, we released vector mapping on Android.
And in 2012, we released it on the -- on iOS.
So mobile actually took this idea of vector
mapping, took this technology, and the first
place we were able to start using it.
Awfully creaky stage.
This is the first place that you were actually
able to get vector mapping.
And why is vector mapping important?
Because it can do all those interesting things
that you saw Berni demonstrate.
You can render data on the fly and respond
to user inputs without having to worry about
roundtripping once again to the server to
get data back in and shove it back into your
application.
So that gives you really interesting things
like camera animation, and I want to actually
give a quick demo of that.
If I can find my
demo now.
Oh, the demo was loaded into the other machine.
Nevermind.
I'm going to move on.
But basically allowing you to do -- many of
the kinds of animations that you've seen both
in the video and live.
We've shown you these kind of animations where
you can zoom in, see these 3D buildings tilt
and pan the map in a very smooth way.
And we're going to be talking a lot about
those in the two mobile sessions -- the two
dedicated mobile sessions.
Ken?
I don't know why that happened.
So the two dedicated mobile sessions on iOS
and Android today and tomorrow as well as
throughout many of our different sessions
the next couple of days.
So we have 17 -- 17 sessions and one codelab
that will be taking place in the next few
days.
So I want to announce today that we're making
updates to both the Android and iOS APIs.
So the Android API got pushed.
It was announced actually in the keynote with
the new Google Play services update.
You will get a new version of the Android
API -- the Google Maps Android API V2.
And we're also announcing that today we're
releasing Version 1.3 of the Google Maps SDK
for iOS.
So the Android API, as you know, is built
into Google Play Services, which means that
any device that has Google Play services automatically
gets updated.
You get -- without you having to do any work.
So any updates, any improvements, bug fixes,
performance management that we can add automatically
updated in the app.
And it brings the power of the consumer, Google
Maps' vector rendering engine into your applications.
When we released in 2011, Google Maps for
Android, the first thing that developers asked
is: How can I use this in my applications?
Now starting last November, you can.
And the Google Maps SDK for iOS is a static
library that you can download and incorporate
into your applications.
And it brings in the power of the Google Maps
application for iPhone and it is available
on both iPhone and iPad devices.
And it allows for very easy integration with
Google Maps and also allows you, therefore,
to use Google's services on your Google Maps.
And we also launched an URL scheme that allows
you to launch the Google Maps application
for iPhone directly from your application
if you don't want to use the SDK.
Let's talk a moment about this data platform.
There's a couple of things I want to highlight.
The first is the tracks API.
So imagine you have an application that does
tracking of your users or some asset or something.
An application that, say, is a social application
so you can track where your friends are located.
Now, imagine you wanted to send -- you wanted
to know minute by minute where somebody using
your application is.
Think about how many queries one person would
be sending to your server in a day.
Say they're using it for ten hours.
That's an easy calculation.
Once a minute for -- for an hour times ten.
That's a lot of pings per person.
Imagine your application is used by 5,000
or 10,000 people.
To track where their friends are in any moment.
You want to know at a frequency more frequent
than once per minute.
That's a lot of queries hitting your server
just to collect location information for individuals.
We've set up the tracks API that allows you
to do just that.
It allows you to present information about
-- to collect information about your users
in Google's Cloud anonymously and then be
able to track those users as they go.
So pulling down location information for each
individual from Google's Cloud without straining
your resources.
Because we've figured out how to do these
sorts of things.
The other data platform that I'd like to mention
is Google Maps engine.
Brian called this out in the keynote.
We're really excited about the Google Maps
Engine platform.
Now, Maps Engine is a platform for uploading
your Geo data to our Cloud services and then
serving that data out in the same infrastructure
and the same way that we serve out data.
So if you want to collaboratively work on
an application on a set of data with a bunch
of other people across the globe and you want
to use high end GIS data and you don't necessarily
-- not all your users are necessarily going
to be developers, they might simply be users.
You can then load those up and build those
out to scale so that you can serve out your
data to a large number of users.
One of the reasons why this is important is
because, again, we get into these queries
per second.
So if you have an application -- I'm going
to say, say you are a local government officer
and you have a GIS shop for, say, the city
of New York.
And a hurricane or some other kind of disaster
comes, a bunch of people might be hitting
your site to find out information about where
to find shelters, where to evacuate, all that
sort of thing.
If all that is running off of Google's data
centers, which are replicated around the world,
you don't have to worry that your servers
are going to go down.
It's served over the same infrastructure that
we use to serve out Google Earth and Google
Maps, and then we allow you to communicate
that to your users.
You choose how many and who.
You can -- it's basically like Google Docs,
you can choose to share it with only a few
people.
You can share it broadly.
You can share it with just an URL.
And then you can -- you can serve that out
to as many -- as many people as you want.
You can serve it out on whatever devices you
want people to reach as well.
And we announced last week that we also added
a new API for it.
This allows you to programatically interact
with the Google Maps platform so you can upload
data and you can edit data.
You can interact with your data dynamically
in the Google Maps platform.
We have traditionally sold this to large enterprises
but we wanted to -- we frequently get asked
at Google I/O, how can I play with it?
And the great news is that you can play with
it today.
Go to the -- if you're here at Google I/O,
go to the Google Maps sandbox and ask them
to sign you up for an account for Google Maps
Engine and we will give you a test account
that will allow you to develop using the Google
Maps Engine platform.
And then it will have API access and you can
also serve out those -- that data on top of
the Google Maps JavaScript API using a Maps
Data Layer.
So we're really excited that you are going
to get a chance to play with the newest, latest
and greatest data platforms that we have on
-- at Google.
I should also mention that the tracks API
is free to play with as well for a limited
number of assets that you're tracking.
So if you want to get started, if you want
to get started with the developer experience
at Google Maps, go to developers.google.com/maps.
Also, some of us will be in the sandbox for
the next three days.
We're excited to talk to you about ow new
platforms and how you're going to get started
using our APIs.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I'm not going to take questions, sorry.
We have seven minutes left.
Do you want to take questions?
Ken will take questions and I will take questions,
too.
Apparently we are taking questions.
We have seven minutes' time, so, before it
runs out.
>>Mano Marks: If you want to ask a question.
Please come to one of the mics here and ask.
If you have a question, come to the mic.
>>> With the new Google Maps API and the ability
to visualize the buildings in 3D, are you
going to provide rendering solutions for people
who want to render stereoscopically.
>>Ken Hoetmer: I think something might have
got lost in the translation.
The update to the Google Maps API is an update
to the base map tiles.
We are not introducing any 3D functionality
at this time.
>>Mano Marks: In the mobile APIs we have 3D
buildings built in.
We don't currently have a solution on mobile
for rendering things stereoscopically.
>>> On Apple maps for iOS you're allowed to
inject your own map layer on top but it doesn't
seem that we're able to do that in the iOS
Google Maps app or anything like that whereas
Google --
>>Mano Marks: Are you talking about a tile
layer of some kind.
>>> Yeah, sure.
Where Google has allowed you to inject the
Google map into your own effect.
I'm wondering if that will be allowed in the
future.
>>Mano Marks: It's built into the Apple maps
application.
We a comment on future features for Google
Maps.
We're really excited that people can build
this, though, into their own applications.
>>>Hi.
How's it going?
>>> It's good.
I have a question about the tracks API, how
different the API is from the Latitude API.
>>Mano Marks: How different is the tracks
API.
>>> How different latitude API from tracks
API?
>>Mano Marks: Latitude.
So the tracks API is designed specifically
for developers who want to not be tied to
other Google Apps like latitude or coordinate.
They want to build out their own.
It's simply you assign an ID and you give
a location and then you upload bunches of
crumbs of that.
Then you build out your own visualization.
>>Ken Hoetmer: The simplest difference.
Latitude was about tracking people.
Tracks API is about tracking anything that
moves.
You can put a GPS sensor on anything and call
it an asset and track it in the tracks API.
>>> Okay.
Thank you.
>>> I notice -- sounds kind of crazy, but
can Google Maps API be extended to Lord of
the Rings or make a searchable map using,
like, I don't know -- make a searchable middle
earth.
>>Mano Marks: Yes, people have done that using
tile overlays to lay them on top of Google
Maps.
So, yeah, in fact, you can.
And if you can get GPS to work, you can do
it on a mobile device.
If you get GPS to work in middle earth.
>>Ken Hoetmer: Google Maps API has been based
on an assumption that it's got the earth underneath
it.
That assumption doesn't need to hold.
You can create, effectively, the same patch
work of tiles for some other world.
Which we used to have in the API for Mars
and moon.
If you can create that and find that map for
middle earth, you can definitely use the maps
API for it.
>>Mano Marks: You would create a custom map
type and you basically provide a mapping between
what your world coordinates are and latitude
and longitude so the maps API knows how to
interact with it.
And, yeah, it's -- check out GTA4.net/map.
You'll see the grand theft auto map rendered
in using the maps API with custom street view.
Very cool.
>>> Thank you.
Of course.
You can use GME, Google Maps engine, to do
it as well.
>>> This is a little bit bigger picture, I
suppose.
You talked about the progression from tiles
to vectors and then to today's announcements
of all search and intent and what you're going
to be next as part of maps.
Where did that come from?
Was it always kind of, you know, something
that was being developed in maps?
The kind of new direction for maps as a contextual
and intent-based tool.
>>Mano Marks: Do you want to answer that?
>>Ken Hoetmer: We have the map here.
>>Brian McClendon: I think the intent overall
is what we've discovered is maps data are
kind of the center of so many of your walk
around carry the phone.
So many of them -- about what the data, I
think I think the maps, you do start to -- geo
fences, motion models, there are things that
we will be able to do in your application.
>>> My question is about Google Earth.
So I've seen there's a lot of innovation with
Google Maps.
You mentioned features and zoom out to space
reminded me of Google Earth.
Can you comment on what the role between Google
Maps and Google Earth is going to be.
>>Mano Marks: It's basically the same team
of people working on both applications.
We're in pretty early stages now with the
new Google Maps and we're seeing a lot of
evolution of the base platforms, the web,
and earth.
We can't announce it right now any changes
to any other platforms that we haven't already
announced.
But, yeah, we're excited about the possibilities
that WebGL will bring us but also we have
over a billion installs of Google Earth around
the world and a very active user base.
>>> Thank you.
>>> I have a higher level question that I
don't know is fair to ask you guys but I'm
going to anyway.
You're delivering the new maps APIs through
the Google Play Services rather than through
sort of platform level changes?
I got the sense that that was coming out at
a broader level for not just maps APIs but
other stuff as well.
I'm assuming that this is driven by platform
update by OEMs and operators.
Is this kind of a broader strategy that Google
is looking at in terms of keeping the Android
platform fresh for developers but not being
bound to the OEMs and operators?
>>Brian McClendon: The simple answer is yes.
The advantage of Google Play services, and
the advantage of any dyanmic library is bug
fixes, updates and the like.
And with the Services going all the way back
to Froyo, it gives developers the opportunity
to reach a wider audience.
>>> Do you guys see that extending further
beyond what was announced today?
Is that a broader endemic like API strategy?
>>Brian McClendon: I think the first version
came out a few months ago.
I think it is an ongoing process.
>>Ken Hoetmer: Take this as the last question
as we are a minute over.
>>> So one of the nice features is to take
our own KML file and have it integrated onto
Google Maps rather than just integrating Google
Maps into our own website.
Do you have additional features with the latest
Google Maps version which allows for more
context specific retrieval of data and KML
or is there anything sort of back and forth
that we can do that will allow for that interaction
to be more intelligent?
>>Mano Marks: We don't have anything to announce
at this point around KML rendering and the
new Google Maps.
So certainly KML is a standard that we helped
pioneer through Keyhole and then Google Earth
and we gave away to the world and we're still
committed it and it is very exciting.
>>Mano Marks: Thanks a lot everyone.
See you in the sandbox.
[ Applause ]